قال رئيس الحكومه الاسرائيليه بنيامين
نتنياهو ان اسرائيل لن توقف الحرب قبل
تحقيق
اهدافها لدي رساله واضحه لاعدائنا ما حدث
في السابع من اكتوبر لن يحدث مجددا هذا
واجب الحكومه برئاسه وهذا سبب تضحيات
جنودنا بحياتهم في الميدان المقاتلون
والضباط في القوات النظاميه وقوات
الاحتياط في الشمال والجنوب يعودون
ويقولون شيئا واحدا نعود قبل اتمام المهمه
وانا اقول لن نتوقف حتى ننتصر ممنوع وقف
الحرب حتى تحقق كافه اهدافها القضاء على
حماس اعاده كل مختطفين وضمان انلا تشكل
غزه تهديدا على اسرائيل اقول ذلك لاعدائنا
واصدقائنا على حد سواء هذه مسؤوليتنا
والتزامنا يجب ان نضع جانبا كل الاعتبارات
الاخرى وان نستمر سويا حتى النصر المطلق